[Music]
andrew starts us off this hour in tampa
hi andrew how are you
good how are you pleasure speaking with
you you too sir how can we help
hey so my question is how do you split
ownership on a home um financially 50 50
if one person
makes pretty much substantially more
than the other
uh are you married
going to be in a year so that's kind of
why i'm
you know i'm asking because we're
definitely going to be looking if you're
married you don't split the ownership
both of you own it joint and severally
you own 100 understood
understood but i meant more financially
so
um let's just say the mortgage payment
oh the mortgage okay all right so how do
we budget
who pays what of the mortgage after
we're married is that your question
correct okay all right
yeah so andrew the way we we look at
that is that once the income hits the
bank account that you guys that it's
both your money i mean like both of you
um
have the same amount of money it doesn't
matter who makes what
you guys are in a marriage and so you
are a team you are one
and we are all about combining your
finances and so that means if you know
your wife stays at home and you work and
your paycheck hits the bank account it's
as much hers as it is yours
um and vice versa so it's not a matter
of who brings it in it's just the fact
that you guys are one
and working as a team so yeah there's
not really a splitting the mortgage it's
uh we're going to pay it together it's
kind of the old-time marriage vows from
the book of common prayer okay for
richer for poor in sickness and health
and here's a phrase they don't ever use
anymore but in the old on in the old
marriage vows
unto thee
all my worldly goods i pledge
used to be part of the marriage vows in
sickness and health richer for poor unto
thee on my worldly goods i pledge and so
and the preacher says and now you are
one
not and now you are a joint venture
let's figure out how to split this up
and so we're going to just take all the
money and put it in a pile and now that
pile of money is our money and we want
to accomplish our dreams our goals
address our fears with that pile of
money and how do we go about that one
thing we're going to do is obviously pay
the mortgage payment because we'd like
to live in this house another thing
we're going to pay the light bill
because we'd like to have electricity we
we we
we you change your pronouns when you're
married you become french we we
okay perfect and then do you believe in
separate checking and then a standard
account to where both of you were on it
nope at all one account
don't need to
you don't need to because you're both
sharing everything there's no secrets
we're married we love each other we have
each other's best interest at heart we
want to cause the other person to win i
want to serve my wife she wants to serve
me we want to accomplish the things we
agree together that we want to
accomplish and we're going to do a
written plan a budget every month that
we both have a vote on
she gets her needs and desires addressed
in that discussion i get my needs and
desires addressed in that discussion
they're both on that piece of paper and
so then the money from the checking
account goes towards what we have
previously agreed on paper called a
budget and so there's no surprises
which andrew i and i hear you though
that i know that that this is kind of
weird advice because now the normal
um
way of going about money and marriage is
that yeah she has her checking account
you have yours you guys split the bills
and that's what it is but
but but this is now we've been we've
been living together now for probably
about two years now engaged so it's it's
at a point to where it's almost like
like you would call it roommates in a
way you are right now you are happy
legally you are roommates today
correct legally after you're married
you're not anymore
it's all one but i mean and it really
pushes that discussion though andre i
would i would encourage you guys if that
makes you uncomfortable for any reason
of like oh gosh we're going to share our
money start asking those questions why
does that make me uncomfortable is there
a am i still wanting a part of my life
that i don't want to give up i mean
those are good questions not just for
your money but for your going into your
marriage because this is a this is just
a a reflection of hey we're going to
share a bed we're going to share our
genetics running around with little kids
in the future like we're going to share
our life together and that includes our
money but if it makes you if that has if
you're hesitant or she's hesitant on
that
i would push into that asap because as a
part of some of your pre-marriage
counseling yeah so here here's some data
points that help that help you with this
as well that that say that this is not
just an opinion okay we've done this
i've done this for 30 years and we've
had 10 million people go through
financial peace university so it is more
than an opinion in that sense anecdotal
evidence there but the actual data says
that the number one cause of divorce is
money fights and money disagreements
and when we can get you to combine
your
income and combine your spending
decisions we're forcing you to combine
your dreams
to combine your fears to combine
and if if our dreams include her going
and getting her masters
that's an hour dream we both want that
for her
right and that's money that's spent
directly on her but it's a part of our
dream okay if our dreams include uh you
getting a nice car that you've always
wanted then that's one of our dreams and
she's happy about that okay so the
you're combining your dreams you're by
forcing you to put the money together
and forcing you to make decisions
together we're forcing you to combine
your value system rather than having a
little secret life off to the side or a
lot of selfishness off to the other side
or something else so the number one
cause of divorce and the second thing we
found the other piece of data in the
largest study of millionaires that's in
the baby steps millionaire's book that
it was just the number one the other day
that i just did um
of the millionaires that we studied uh
it was like 86
a tribute
uh they're becoming millionaires to the
fact that they were that their spouse
was on the journey with them
not they were dragging a reluctant
spouse or not they were over on the side
having their own little side hustle and
they just worked it out and their spouse
just was oblivious no they were on the
journey with them there's something
about both there's an old thing called
the uh the marriage what is that called
the marriage
uh it's a marriage advantage or
something like that that there's a there
was a study done about 25 years ago it's
probably dated now but it showed that
people that are married and have healthy
marriages they they live longer
they make more money
uh they're better in their careers
and so it was a marriage advantage
that's not the right phrase another word
for it i forget what it's called but
anyway that's what so all of that ties
but it all only works when you do this
combo thing yeah this combined
uh unified thing and you create a level
of unity in in your relationship and in
your marriage through the money lens
that nothing else will do yes and this
is all really big picture stuff but to
andrew like when you guys sit down and
do a budget you both get a line item in
the budget so like my husband
there's a winston line item there's a
rachel line item so i can still go to
target and shop or buy something online
and i'm not like having to like go to
him with every single thing like i have
money to spend and but it's all coming
out of the same place it's all coming
out of the budget we agreed on it's
coming out of the same checking account
so it's not stripping away
your individual freedom you still have
the ability to like what you like and
spend where you want to spend but you're
doing it together
as one yeah it makes all the difference
in the world
on your marriage and on the probability
of your building well